As we said, one major component of bipolar disorder is depression. A person
needs to be clinically depressed for the most part, but they also need to
experience mania. Now to help you remember the symptoms of the mania stage,
there is a mnemonic device that you can use. And that's DIGFAST. First we have
distractability, then indiscretion, grandiosity, flight of ideas, activity
increased, sleep, which during the mania stage, you have a decreased need for
And talkativeness. There are different types of bipolar disorder, but we're
only going to discuss three here. Let's start with bipolar I and bipolar II.
Bipolar I is more severe. That's because the person meets the clinical criteria
for major depression and for mania for at least seven consecutive days. On the
other hand, with bipolar II the individual meets the criteria for major
depression and the criteria for hypomania. Hypomania episodes are similar to
the symptoms of mania. So think about that DIGFAST mnemonic device that we just
spoke about. However, these episodes are much shorter in duration, they last
for at least four consecutive days. So we see the difference between hypomania
and mania as the distinction between someone having a more severe form of
bipolar or less severe form. Nevertheless, whenever it's bipolar I or II, it's
clear to see how it can be a difficult disorder to live with. In fact, it can
be exhausting. However, there are treatments available which we'll discuss in
our next lesson. Of the third disorder we'll discuss is called cyclothymia.
This is the milder, but longer-lasting form of bipolar disorder. This has both
manic and depressive episodes, but it's less severe than bipolar II disorder,
because in the manic and the depressive symptoms never reach the criteria of
major depression or even hypomania.